maybe he'll find out let's get the cream
up and I'll proof get something right
here some of those no ballistics on it
it's Cougars great okay oh hey guys um
Trey eyerly place - what's my last name
wife it's my wife through Pendleton for
a deadly reunion with Baron J production
he's so vain Baron J can you look alike
how did you hear about the production
attraction
uh actually bearing cousin it's actually
our second film that we're doing we have
one is in post right now called the
condo which is a comedy and he sent me
the script about this one as you would
care that I want to play and I chose
stools interesting character and so when
did you actually get the first script
yeah I had gotten the first group in his
ironic did you say that because we're
writing script right now as we're
shooting probably about a month ago and
it was it was likeable then it was like
the family has seen the Big Chill or
something like that
friends getting together so I liked it
so it really is just based off for good
characters but now we're doing the most
unorthodox thing of shooting I caught it
shoot on the fly because the writer is
sitting next room he's writing the pages
as we're shooting right now he's writing
what's happening next so we have no idea
I can t know how I get killed now if I
do get you so I don't know what's going
on how soon were you getting the changes
while you're on set like suppose you go
with their seconds like literally like
we've been changing things like we'll
start one scene while he's writing two
or three other scenes and I okay here
the pages guys caught learn your lines
so this would be the most a coal read
feature film how do you feel about
actors investing in their own projects
and they're wearing two hats one is an
actor what does it mean how do I feel
about actors wearing - am I love it
because who are you going to invest you
invest in yourself the problem that
occurs is when you're in the scene to be
an actor and they still in the producer
Mona whatever actually to stop bearing
out a couple of times I look you're not
a producer right now you're in the scene
I need you
and it's hard when you hit we're not
accustomed to doing that and then uh but
then also for some actors who are
putting their money and have a sense of
entitlement that they really should not
have what they feel they can make their
own demands and how much do you put it
to you know Mia's life is like that so
it's a collective thing but it it's a
good thing like I said for the most part
you're investing yourself a person a
prize you believe in put those egos
sometimes take control and get away with
some people we all have an ego that was
a new addition that just happened today
no one had powers until today so now yes
I just added it today like literally
about an hour ago
so I'm like instead of George Lucas if I
could be the next Star Wars or some you
know some being like this that's crazy
how long have you been in LA in LA for
15 years from where Chicago outside nice
yeah do you think you'll stay in LA I
would like to wou just a mecca of
entertainment so I love I love doing
this so but I will wants to get to the
different levels I would like to have
places other where elsewhere and then
fly it for work coming to work I don't
really want to raise a family here but I
love hello you cannot beat LA what's
your typical day like when you get up in
the morning yeah
what are you devoting to acting and what
are you devoting to Trey and what are
you devoting to work outside of acting
mmm good question
I can I devote everything I think I'm
obsessed with it it's my obsession it's
my passion so you know just for studying
things on TV other actors that I admire
or
reading a lot scripts I like what I just
have been doing now I like to watch true
Hollywood stories behind us he likes
people's other people's journeys of what
they have done to know the rises and
falls doing it so I will do a lot of
stage plays I love doing stage plays
that's the most organic part of acting
give a different other people when
everyone running like anything that's
dealing with the entertainment I just
love doing it so but for me that's I'm
consuming my self with that I really
don't take vacations because I can't
enjoy it because I'm not where I would
like to be or like I need to be so if
I'm on a vacation so I'm still reading
scripts I'm still doing some researching
I remember the person was saying earlier
about going on actors access la casa
look at the breakdowns look just
everything that's in a backstage just
everything I just try to engulf myself
with as much information as possible of
the true Hollywood stories you've been
watching whose is very similar to your
own it's becoming Morgan Freeman because
it took Morgan free month and he didn't
really get his break break and he was
like 44 he had done a lot of stage
acting in New York he was going back and
forth when things dried out whatever so
right now I'm at a pinnacle where middle
tier like I just finished don't want to
play with a red of divine you want to
hit me and let it see a time nine-time
Grammy Award winner didn't another play
with Kelly Price and and jackée so I'm
on that tier and and I say so and I'm
tell me what to tell my age it's not 44
but it's getting up there and so things
are starting to happen now getting a lot
of work so I'm it's almost parallel to
tell him in a sense and he's brilliant
he's great so I'll take that what keeps
you motivated every day the passion and
the drive to say I was like I told my my
parents when I was leaving to come out
here I'm gonna die doing this so there's
nothing I can't accept anything less
than that even if I stay at this level
which I hope I won't I'm still doing
everything I I can I want to do to
pursue this you know that's why it's
called the pursuit of happiness
he's always pursuing something so I'm
pursuing this until you get to that
point and you still want it but you
still want to continue to do more you
want to create more you want to well I
do want to write my own projects and
direct and just own your own studio you
can green line is I just
love this were they okay with that
decision when you said this is my this
is what I want to do with my life
however it turns out they were ok but
they were worried because like anybody
else you know the competition and know
that the chances are slim to none and
the slim is already gone but they know
I've always been very responsible I mean
I was national Dean's List high school
college I've always been star roll and
stuff like that so they knew that it
once I set my mind to it and nothing's
going to stop it regardless but they
have always been supportive to this day
so yeah ok so you said you've been here
15 years in LA hmm from Chicago okay if
there had been a handbook that someone
was going to deliver to you and say Trey
this is for you and you will learn all
this but it's gonna take 15 years what
do you wish was in that handbook money
no because I survived Elaine is so
expensive if you're a struggling actor
you anybody comes out here the cost of
living is so high you can't it's hard
for you to get a regular job because you
have to try to pursue you have to do
auditions it means all that so you'll
get fired or you get laid off from your
job so you had the money to be at that
cushion to be able to pursue this then
yeah but as the questioning is I give
you another oh that's good I like that I
like that book actually I wish someone
had handed me that but what else in that
book that would tell you different
things don't waste your time with this
spend more time on that
do you wish someone had given to you but
that you've learned now that you could
then hand that book to someone here's
the irony of that because you just never
know because there's a lot of when I
first got here I were touched by some of
these different showcases or whatever
don't go there rip off because why these
castles righteous they set these
showcase they try to make their own
money pay your own bills but the same
time because they're not really invested
to really find somebody but if they do
Oh
each pilot is guys so it's a it's not is
so unorthodox and there's nothing it's
not a set blueprints so to have that
book it's like just my experience just
experience it should be is just like a
book of just experiences and you just
learn like wow that's why I watch those
different backstories or anybody else
because there's nothing the most
important thing is just to commit
whatever is going to be you're going to
do you know and ice and ice to do your
research to commit to whatever they care
is gonna be whatever in choo-choo okay
if you want to work at Home Depot you
know it's like you want to be the head
cashier you have to work you have to
commit to whether it is you know put the
hours in the work so that book mainly is
just to say just to to stay focusing on
what you want to do and just to enjoy
the experience even even the bad things
are gonna happen so you can still shapes
and Mo's you who you are think about
things you wanted went through a life of
like I would never do that again but it
still prepares you to be able to look
out for anything else or to do anything
else so yeah cuz cuz even if I were to
write a book right now I think it would
be very informative but at the same time
it's it's everybody else is their
journey so it's nothing in particular I
can get from that I said I just get as
much knowledge as you can story of a bad
audition that she walked out and your
heart sank and you said this was
horrible and you actually got the job
hmm they had audition and I think
episode actually this ironically who got
my to leave here tonight I'm doing two
ways right now leave this movie tonight
at 7:00 when finding out to go to
someone it's called blackout that I
booked and I anything else forget it
because my voice is not my regular voice
is raspy doing too much and normally I'm
very committed and focused in the same
but my voice started cracking I just my
mind was like they're not gonna hire me
so I still gave it to ever but not the
effort I would have really have given it
because I guess I'm limited I'm a
handycam right now cuz I could do so
much and other things guys yeah I never
say I'm sorry not this sorry guys you
know it's so no I'm sure you did great
it's okay I know I did it's alright and
I left out and they hit me and called me
the next they're like which availability
for that we start shooting them like
serious cuz I really thought was a
debacle you know I mean cuz I've because
I forgot a couple of hours I can I start
over it and you know but once you at
beat I'm also on both sides of the
camera I also produce at Sony Screen
Gems so for me when I was somehow
isolating a casting process complicated
for casting if they control their
audition
then I and I like they like open know me
there what I'm looking for is cuz they
make a mistake they know how to control
audition then I'll work every but makes
mistakes I was telling I was telling the
princess of the other day when I had I
was in Miami ain't gon set up any given
Sunday and now but she no mess up like
six sets I was like I was like 19 I saw
fresh on Chicago's I'm not knowing the
process I'm like he's not great although
he is how you are but when I thought he
kept messing up I'm like could you think
watching if you were just a regular
person they get it on the first take you
just it wears with it you just see them
they just shoot it now no one goes over
and over and over again so if you
understand that producers directors I
mean and cast like okay we know you're
gonna make them a statement how do you
recover from that mistake and how do you
control your scene so but maybe not
apology I think on some kids know me you
somebody like that you think that
they're new they're green they're
particle you make a mistake or excuse on
a set I think you're hired
but something within them saw something
within me and said hey and I'll be going
to shoot that tonight so you told your
parents that this is what you're going
to do did you ever have a particularly
bad day here where you were very close
to saying I'm done with LA no I have
many of those bad days I'm like I'm fed
up with a lot of things but I semi die
doing this
and once I committed to that I just what
it is because I used to work at Donald
Trump casino I was a you know do the
table games from craps to roulette to
whatever so I have a trait so I can go
to Vegas any time and get a job making
$80,000 a year
come became a pit boss I can go to San
Diego work at the Harris case oh I know
I have safety nets but I choose not to
do that I'm this is what I'm gonna do
regardless can you recall the audition
that changed your life and also took you
further up that that tear that you were
talking about earlier wanna really be an
audition wood it was from the look at
the parties I have done I submitted
myself to this man named Donald B Welch
who's he's a playwright director and
he's also starting to go into more into
film he's also Will Smith's partner will
and it's coming over Brook has invested
in Don Welch
and I haven't tried to work with him for
years I said to my materials and stuff
and he usually does plays like in 99
Cedars a little smaller place but it's
because of his brand he's very well
respected everybody comes out to see him
it wasn't while he doesn't matter at a
bigger like a 1,500 seated like Wilshire
Ebell Pantages something like that so at
the eight years of pursuing him he
finally said I have something for you
and it was a lead in this play was
called walk by faith and that was with
Kelly Price and and Jackie Harry who won
an Emmy and that's what's going on right
now that's starting the change and the
change because I'm getting all these
different calls from different people
because they saw when they see you on
the stage with people like that it's not
just who already have made it like like
relativize been in the game for 25 26
she's won original dream girls on
Broadway so you see somebody see me on
stage with that type caliber person
holding my own and I'm playing opposite
of her it's like people see you in a
different light than how they make a
mouse now we're starting to happen so
that was start the transition now it's
my wife I just want to say movie if it
wasn't right I am and I wouldn't be here
on this he's the one who got me in
contact with the producer said he had a
role for me he came through and Here I
am now shooting boots in he plays the
husband you know what's great about
working with right we maybe met maybe
three years ago so the fact that we're
playing husband and wife on set it's
perfect because we already know each
other it's an advantage because we have
that chemistry already of just knowing
each other outside of set so it's like
you know we're doing our things together
it's like you know we really are in the
moment so it's perfect and the problem
with that is is because I've been
hitting on her for like three years and
it's hard to play my wife I can't even
kiss her because we don't like each
other so it's bittersweet and it's not
really that fun is but seriously we're
red-hot Sony so it's not like the
typical
marriage thing but and I think about the
way Hollywood works it out and I'm glad
that she even sat here because a lot of
people are here we'll fill your head
with dreams I'll tell you that because
they're trying to sleep with you
whatever and I was in the beginning
but at the same time I'm a truthful
about what I say and so kind of I guess
people saying I can do this for you do
that I said listen because I also
produced like I told you I said but if I
had something and you're right for I
will call you I've caught up a place and
stuff before and this happened and she
was one of people I was paying by anyway
and because we would say they allowed me
to be able to choose my wife and I so we
had this one girl who was good also but
something happened with her and she was
out the country or worse I would I had
her first
you know she had gotten back in the
country just I haven't she called me
it's not serendipitous this thing is cuz
she called me when I was about the car
you to see if you're back in town want
know just give you the real off the road
for my wife and so happen there she's
like I told her who the producer was she
had just saw him the same day it was the
same day the same day something like is
given it's meant to happen so and so
here she is so so some people do are
true of they weren't very rare I just
want to love even know that you know
people can be serious about what they
say even though they might have another
agenda still to be a man or woman are
they're worse thank you yes